apporter la paix Denis Villeneuve après
4 ans de travail un enfant demi ils sont
rentrés en grand première mondiale à la
Mostra de Venise
enthousiaste tous à la fois
je vais te soulager quand je vais dans
la salle que les choses au moment où on
se parle je progresse entraînement
rapidement il y a tellement de
changement au quotidien que moi je vais
croire quand je vais te
dirait un exercice de lâcher prise ça va
être sorti dans un contexte et parfait
puis si j'accepte le fait que c'est la
sécurité des gens avant tout on va voir
ça dans les territoires comment ça se
passe
femme de John que j'ai lu je sais pas
combien de fois un livre à la fois
complexe lézard qui se bat contre les
Atrides pour la production de l'épée
gériatrique qui permet d'avoir des
divisions de voyage et voyager dans la
galaxie part de religion politique
d'écologie et j'ai l'impression que la
folate se retrouve beaucoup de Denis
Villeneuve que ça va plus ancien modèle
parcours
retrouver il va se retrouver on va
trouver son identité on est en contact
avec un peuple qui va l'accueillir après
le désert et c'est comme ça que
quelqu'un puisse enfin définition
d'identité au contact d'une autre
culture moi ça m'avait beaucoup touché à
l'époque
la pas touché la sorte de données en
décembre 2020 vous avez créé ce qu'est
la décision de de sortir aux États-Unis
simultanément le film se réduit au max
sur ce sujet là où
est
le problème
[Musique]
des films je crois pas du tout à ce
modèle
les vacances j'ai revu tous vos films et
que je me posais la question suivante
parce que vous êtes ni à Bécancour vous
êtes secondaire collégial à
Trois-Rivières cinéma de l'UQAM comment
est-ce possible d'arriver Houssiaux
Hollywood
[Musique]
a des gens qui m'ont pas pris mes 1
derniers conseils de j'ai reçu avant de
commencer à travailler à allez-vous ça a
été ce matin qui m'a dit
de me
contacter
je ne peux ouvrir la porte à une série
télé a d'autres femmes enceintes qui est
assez vaste merci sur quoi vous
travaillez présentement sur notre groupe
Roger
[Musique]
j'essaie de pas trop mes papiers je suis
quelqu'un qui est assez monomaniaque que
j'essaie de travailler sur un projet à
la fois
donc évidemment la deuxième partie d'une
priorité
[Musique]
un film
depuis longtemps
prends une place
je souhaite tout le meilleur pour deux
bientôt merci merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]